words before i let silvio speak and that
is welcome to the third day of our
symposium and our last day and again i
want to give a round of applause to all
the speakers so far
and that i'm extremely grateful for all
of you who come from far i know the
traveling these days again is a little
bit of questionable but uh some of you
know that i did a lot of emotional
manipulation to make sure that you come
here in person
and i have proud to say that my powers
are still
even though my kids have been out of the
house for a while i am i'm still good at
it um
and uh
wonderful so we have um an exciting day
in front of us and who better
to start than
you know our very own
silvio in the sense that silly is a
graduate of berkeley and we were in
graduate school together as a whole a
bunch of people here were graduate
students with us so where are they mike
looby
there he is
and then there's a few others who who
else is here
oh dan gasfield that's right and umesh
and sandy where is she
and uh howard and that's right howard
where are you you even took over our
office
and uh
in russell
where's russell
there he is yeah so and um thank you
very much
so sylvio uh i think yesterday prasad
was uh
no i think he was um giuliani was
introducing people saying that they need
no introduction but in the mit tradition
we say that sylvia because one time
leonid levin was introducing him or
something he said he deserves no
introduction
um
so it was a
you know a command of the english
language but uh
silvio is a sort of a giant intellectual
giant
and i know this from first-hand
experience we've been working with him
for so many years and his research has
been in cryptography and complexity
theory in
algorithms and mechanism design
and his recipient of the touring award
and many other awards bbva award and so
forth uh and the most important thing is
that now what he's going to talk about
is his new passion and in sylvia's
tradition when he gets into something
he's all in
and
he will tell us about we the people
agree welcome sylvia thank you chef
all right everybody great to be here and
back in berkeley and so what i want to
talk about is a byzantine agreement
which uh was an old subject right is and
they created a true theoretical rage
so my shafty and i were there was a rage
about the roma
with manuel about a public key
cryptography but there was another rage
which was about the byzantine agreement
so it was in 1979 pretty much when i
first of all arrived to berkeley
introduce of a piece of
showstock and lamport and then
everybody worked on it lynch fischer
paris or michael raven with a common
coin with them um
michael benoir cynthia work you name it
it was agora over theoreticians all in
love with this problem and then the one
thing in common to say this problem is
very important this problem will have a
great application this problem blah blah
blah blah it's like in true theory
tradition in which you see that
something is important because your gut
tells you so okay and then only later
it takes you know 25 years if you're
lucky 50 years if you're less lucky but
somehow with the fundamental intuition
some actually i prove it right
so i'd like to talk because this is the
summon institute of theoretical computer
science i mean not the best building but
this is the occasion we are celebrating
to tell you about about the basic
theoretical problem and why it does pop
up in the somehow rightfully so in in
practice so let me start with
telling you
i mean i'm going to be very very very
rough right because uh first of all i
have 40 minutes
second of all there is uh exactly in the
morning and because the subject is
actually complex so
but i'm going to be around for uh for a
while to answer some questions perhaps
so what is it buzz interview is a
communication protocol somehow and
people get together they must talk talk
talk talk talk to each other and as long
as more than two-thirds are honest which
means adhere to the protocol
then the guarantees to fundamental
properties consistency and agreement
consistency means
just in case
should it happen but every player some
are goodness are bad you see the picture
right and that they start with the same
value then at the end of the
conversation
all the good players should end
in their mind with that value
so if all start
with the same value and the same value
second property agreement
even if we start with all random
different values at the end of the
conversation
all the good player
should stay
with this a common value it doesn't
matter which because it now is not
defined right everybody starts but he
has to be a common body so
the protocol of saying no matter what
happens
in no time agree on 27 is this a
byzantine agreement protocol no because
satisfies the agreement property
everybody has the same value 27 but it
doesn't satisfy that if we start with 53
we should end with 53 right so
it takes a while to figure out that
actually this is an interesting problem
and that and that is actually meaningful
but somehow you can actually see
that is a very premier way
to keep a consistent view of the world
in the presence of false
so the bad guys can do anything they
want they can coordinate not coordinate
everything but at the end of these two
properties must be satisfied because
it's very important as the original
thing say if you are going to all attack
there is this is an order attack or
retreat
if all the good guys attack they will be
victorious if they all be retreating
they are going to be
safe but this part attack and party
retreat we are going to be defeated so
agreement is crucial but consistency is
also crucial otherwise there is no
meaningful
now
what do we want to agree on now the
point that i'm going to make in this
talk is that we want to agree
or what is the next block in a public
chain
okay that's what we want to be agreeing
and solely says well these problems was
we go back 35 years
it better have actually a protocol for
solving in fact we have several
beautiful protocols but there are
challenges these protocols were very
slow
defined as law the maximum number of
participants in a practice in a
practical setting for byzantine
agreement was 12
12 in a blockchain where presumably
you're going to have a billion people
participating
and moreover the seto player was fixed
at defining in advance
in a blockchain people come and go join
and leave
no way so right so that is not good so
let me tell you a little bit of the
history about this problem
so besides the definition and the first
protocol there is a theorem fisher lynch
and patterson to say
you have to talk a lot that's why islam
if you have say
a million participants and you suspect
that a third is law you have to talk
three hundred thousand three hundred
thirty five thousand
plus one
times
okay
all right
and turns out that people felt oh that
is a really a fundamental thing but if
you look at the proof
the proof doesn't say so let's assume
the protocol is deterministic the proof
took it for granted
but somehow the wolf only works for the
deterministic
and then michael then benoir they say
well a second we could do something
better with probabilism we can tolerate
a waiver much fewer than a third a
quarter of the bad guys
and that is a bit too optimistic why
because you know if uh you have a
million players
one in a thousand can be dishonest we
know that perhaps we submit the two of
the optimistic
michael raven says hey i have a constant
round
n over four militias a bit not exactly n
over three
but that required a trusted third party
which is not easy
to find
then somehow it was my first phd this is
granted
to paul feldman then pesach feldman
and uh and it was a constant round
n over
three militias
so that was in the violator finally was
a really n over phrase the maximum
controller rate now you can tolerate it
that much in constant round what else
you want well
the paper was 75 pages long and the
constant
was a six thousand so i told you to one
two three four five things
what is
of communication among friends of your
aerial computer scientists
okay by the way interesting enough
including my
protocol
there was without the cryptography
and so and if you used cryptography
cryptography was used by the lev and uh
in 83 but only two
shrink the number or augment the number
of
bad guys you can tolerate somehow not to
uh to speed things up things were slow
still but you could tolerate a little
bit more okay so that problem was
evolving having you know papers written
confidence a bit about it and so and so
forth
recently as you all know and i took
actually notice of this very very late
maybe five years ago from the first time
i i asked somebody could you explain to
me bitcoin what it's about okay so but
there was a rage going on
anyway actually it's a big challenge so
the blockchain
what is the aspiration
the aspiration is a decentralized
database
so the database is not saying i have a
copy you have a copy and we update our
home copy in such a way to satisfy the
following three properties
everybody can read what is written
anybody can write an entry in this thing
and nobody can alter
what has been written in a block or the
order of the block
you say you know
fine
i've seen
more challenging things well let me tell
you
that vets is really
no that is a novelty for humanity and
let me tell you why
everybody of us in this room as uh maybe
somebody is so young that they know not
the
scene but i were part of the
communication revolution right it used
to be very hard to to write things and
communicate them so right now a few
years ago even you take with a
push a button and your message say on
facebook reaches millions of people
but
when you receive such a message on
facebook do you know
that the entire world has received the
same message that you have received no
you don't
so the difference here is between
communication and common knowledge you
see the first property readable by
everyone that's the toughest one to do
the other stuff you know
kept all they can make sure that you
know you cannot alter data that's what
cryptography is good at but to guarantee
that what i see
has been seen by everybody on earth no
matter what
and i can bank on it that's a different
story that is common knowledge and by
the way
common knowledge
is incredible it's a first for humanity
and particularly in a
in an age of alternative facts and
things that's a very big thing
to guarantee okay the potential of this
aspirational blockchain is incredible
who does not like a database cannot be
altered who does not like transparency
who does not like the ability to
generate trust among people who barely
know each other
however
there is a difference between aspiration
and technology
if you launch a protocol and you write a
blockchain on top of it it's like to
saying beware of a dog you don't have a
dog
okay
but another lies you know if people
believe it
they don't they leave you alone so
so it is very good by the way as humans
to raise our respiration as eyes as
possible that's our duty
but
at some point we've sustained our
aspiration with some real technology
otherwise our aspiration will remain up
high in the sky
so
technology about what what is difficult
here
not securing the chain
this is done by prehistoric
cryptography defined prehistoric
done before
shafi and i had to do anything
cryptographic okay
we are in the jurassic okay good so
the odd part is adding the next block
not because i cannot take a block and
add it on because adding the next block
means what i'm adding is visible by
everybody and i know that this is the
case and everybody who sees and knows
that this is the case that is the other
part
say so gee
isn't this what we just do by the
agreement of a block
but remember is very very very slow
requires all these other uh
fake special player no so how do they
solve the problem
now first of all they solve it by pr
they invented a new word consensus
sounds good
is a very sophisticated world everybody
says the algorithm or consensus invest
blockchain works like this investor
works like this
let me tell you right away consensus is
not by something agreement whatever it
is let me tell you what it is
so traditional consensus work like this
you see a blockchain you have to figure
out first of all
to isolate the longest
chain consisting of blocks with all
valid transactions
okay what is an invalid transaction i
make a payment to you for more than the
money that i own which is invalid let me
give you an example so this is the
longest chain and so what you want to do
if if somehow is your turn by whatever
algorithm they use to append the block
you should append the block to the
longest valid chain that you see
and say
question
what if if i find two or more chains of
equal length maximum length and all
valid choose one at random and append
back to the block the end all right
let's save here whoever has it for work
miners in delegate approvals take
delegates whatever you want to call them
here is the blocks and so
the blue player asuma beta is a airtime
to other
other of one block over here and the red
player
adds a block over there
what
why
remember the rule elongate the longest
chain why do i'm adding things you know
a little bit below
because
maybe the blue player says that block bk
plus 1 contain an invalid transaction so
is is
the validity elongated the valid the
longest chain is not valid but according
to him is valve is chain
whatever is a reason
i didn't see it because when you add a
block right remember
i have a database in my computer you
have database on your computer we update
this database we want to have a
guarantee that we are in sync but we are
not in sync simultaneously
right so he may not have seen block pk
bk plus one
and in such a case i elongate this
and thirdly i may be bad saw me i had to
elongate the longest block no i
elongated this but at this point even
though these two blocks are added by
malicious people the next black player
here is honest
applies the rule
too long has changed all valid
he appends over there
okay
that's bizarre the rule
okay
and what happens to the shortest chain
chain eventually vanishes because if
everybody appends to the long longest
chain over there
right so this guy vanishes with all the
payments and all transactions they are
containing it
so in other words you cannot rely on a
block
because it may disappear because some
other
chain can get you know from
from
sneak up from behind and become longer
okay
so therefore
this notion of consensus
is a drip drip drip eventual consensus
okay
so let me explain it a little bit better
here is the semantics
hey jim all right
thank you for giving me occasion to take
a drink
i'll be brief
okay
so
okay so
what is
this consensus how can we conceptualize
it
assume that i want to add right now a
block right so here i think i'm adding a
block
because i'm the order is elongated
branch in in essence i'm voting that the
block before me
i give them a check mark it's a good
block and by the way i'm not showing
also the one before
if somebody adds a block to mine is
actually adding another check to the
block and somebody will say adds another
check
wow this block bk it better be
valid because look
one player two player three player vote
for it
how many players we have a billion oh
so what does this mean one two three
votes
it means very little so
essentially
how deep should be in other words how
votes should have collected bk before
you feel safe enough to say this block
will remain on the chain
can you ever
feel
truly safe
no
but you know
for a while when if if i think it's
valid if you think it's valid and my
wife thinks it's violence your spouse
thinks it's violent it better be valid
that's somehow the logic at some point i
stopped worrying about
and
and go overflow
why this algorithm of consensus is so
so
so weak
because
byzantine agreement is hard that's how
people had to do if we cannot agree they
will do anything to not not to be linked
to an impossible to run by something
again right
so but this
algorithm that i show you with the drip
drip drip consensus
it is the atlas who is sustaining right
now
a trillion dollars of market cap this is
incredible
in fact it is incredible
but that's what it's based on okay
all right
so ideally what do you want to do
whoever byzantine agreement as a notion
you want to agree
on every block
so at the block
i'm i'm proposing this block
we the people agree add another block we
the people agree add another block we
the people agree
is this possible
yes
but we have to know and i want to prove
to you give you some indication that
this actually indeed is possible okay
because now we have to to be we must
reach byzantine agreement
not between a maximum of 12 people but a
billion people need it
right but if we can do we have chains we
do not branch we have a little bit law
in order we
somehow proceed in a much more rigorous
and and uh and conceptually good fashion
so
i want to give you an idea of ours is
done and i'm going to give you a choice
do you prefer the main ideas that is a
right as relaxing day of respect or do
you want to see the gory details
i think that
the clear idea is that how about the
main ideas
okay i want to share two very simple
ideas
because by the way the core ideas are
always a very simple and beautiful the
complexity comes naturally so at least
you must stick to to the core idea
the core radii is very good so i have a
billion people had to agree i'm going to
do it in two steps right the first step
is that is a player reduction somehow
i'm going to select
1000 people out of a billion but it's
pretty good shrinking of the problem
right is an order of
10 to the three three orders of magnets
not bad
second well a fuzz people rich agreement
is also very hard so to solve another
thing to solve a byzantine agreement
which is good enough to agree in one
second between a thousand people all
over the earth
this is a two problem i want to show
give some idea to do this
let me tell you about the player
reduction
it happens in three magic places
the magic is going to be replaced by
math but
it's easier to think about magic
phase number one
about how fast some players
are publicly randomly selected among all
these billion players
how by magic
among whispers and players there is a
two-thirds honest majority in the
selected committee
by magic
and then this committee runs
byzantine agreement
and propagate the digitally signed
result so
assume now that you know who these one
faster committee members are
by hypothesis
and then
you see a block
which has say the signature digital
signage over 700 of these
1000 people but you know what they are
that is the next block there cannot be
another right because you can have a two
overlapping majority that's
that's the idea
good
still in the magic phase let's do some
sanity check remember we must satisfy
consistency
so let's assume that among the billion
people somehow everybody started with
the same value
okay now i have this committee
with about a one thousand
but if everybody starts with the same
value no matter how choose the committee
invest committee everybody starts with
the same value
and therefore after these 1000 people
run byzantine agreement all the honest
will agree on that value
and then
once they
sign it
and they are in a great super majority
and you see a block signed by this
committee with a super majority then you
know that is the block and thereby
all the billion people
stop too so first i think i let a
committee
figure it out the committee figure is
out of the same thing that i think and i
agree on what the committee the majority
of the committee said the end
but consistency works
about agreement we start with all kinds
of different values
well we get 1000 people
but now
they also have random values in their
heads
but the byzantine agreement means
that if there is a
honest majority they will agree on the
same value and therefore everybody will
agree on the same value too
wonderful
well how about one is the majority well
here i'm a cheater a little bit right so
i have to lose a little bit i must
assume a bit not two thirds but say
something a bit more anything epsilon
more would work but say three quarters
are honest
then at this point you know that's why
when 1000 is needed you want to and 1000
is don't hold me on it he's 3 000 it
doesn't matter what is uh all one among
your editions so is a thousand i want to
guarantee that there is going to be a
honest majority
okay what is the probability that i want
to guarantee that in the committee there
is a honest majority
we chose an algorithm
a way if the probability is over not
having an honest majority should be
one in 10 to the 18.
10 to 18 is a very strange number of
course it is because i made it up
but let me tell you why i made it up
because i'm saying that
10 to 18 happens to be
with the amount of seconds from the big
bang until now so if you produce
one block a second which is a veritable
clip you have to wait for the age of a
universe for something going wrong
with these type of things everybody
agrees with it doesn't matter anymore
very good
so and once you have a two honest
majority we have
an agreement
and therefore done good
how the hell we do this player reduction
who randomly select the home right
that's what they have to do from a
billion player to a millionaire
no one so the way
algon does it is vet these committee
members secretly select themselves that
means that in the privacy of my computer
you and my person on your computer
you run a cryptographically fair lottery
in fact let me tell you what that means
in which the probability of winning in
this particular example is one over a
million so a billion divided a million
is roughly 1 000 but you want right
and i cannot cheat because it's a
cryptographic effect so even if i have
nation state full of super super super
computer
i cannot shoot so think about it that
i have a a lever of a cryptographic
slotted machine i can lower the level
only once two cases if i lower and lose
nobody is going to listen to me at all
if i lower and win i get a winning
ticket namely a
mathematical profit a part of this
committee and i and whoever else
exhibits this proof we are going to
discuss to agree we are going to conduct
the basically that's the idea
okay invest is super fast why how long
does it take me to lower this level one
microsecond
or computation
nothing
all right so then
okay now i have
somehow give you an idea and now have a
[ __ ] big community now this far some
people like to agree how the hell they
do it
so let me tell you
in a way that actually once we do it we
do it in three rounds
unless it can be generous we give it a
six rounds okay not at all
and we can tolerate another three
and by the way this is not
blockchain grade not because of the free
but because we are going to make a lot
of simplifying assumptions
and that again is what theory really
does the the genius of theory is to
figure out
the level of discourse very often
how much you should get a model that is
rich enough
meaningful enough to find the brilliant
idea that we come up with and is our job
and then having the idea that once we
solve in this model we can actually
enlarge it and it's really an art more
than a science to find where the model
is
so the model
i'm going to make you know
simplification in the communication with
the serial model i'm assuming that these
values
can be arbitrary values like a block is
a bit is that 0 1 that's another big
simplification
and then i'm going to make my assuming
that i have this
magic coin available to describe the
zest of idea
okay
let me tell you about the model the
model is the complete synchronous
network let me start with complete
either the player
is invasive theoretical model is joined
by a secure channel with any other
player which before is easy to draw with
a billion
beta or even a thousand is a much
different graph it's totally unrealistic
furthermore the network is synchronous
what does it mean
but at every clock tick i post a message
for you for you for you for you
and at the next clock tick puck the
message is received unaltered because it
comes from me right so and nobody has
seen it it's because it's in a private
channel
all right
so in the adversarial model that the
versailles motor says it can corrupt
at the beginning
a third of us and no more
at the beginning
silvio
i know adversaries how to be dynamic
but we had to start with somewhere okay
because to describe something simple
this adversary
has decided who is the button is wrong
and then now he cannot change his
mind okay
so over the investigative adversary
controls coordinates
he sees all the
good good messages before we seeing what
is the bad messages is very strong
but to be clear
because each player plays as a dedicated
line either diversity wants to hear to
this conversation he must either corrupt
the best player or corrupt the other
player at the end of the line or cut
them both
and cannot stop a message from good
player to good player
nor can inject messages in a secure line
right so and when you player i receive a
message on the channel i to j you know
that this message come from player j
see vettii actually captures
what really is different in the
distributed computation
because
i receive something i know it comes from
you but i don't know if others are
receiving the same thing that i'm doing
right because all this in this proper
child this simplification of the moral
as the richness of the problem and yet
it's so simplified we can actually
tackle it
right
that model is trigg enough okay so now
i'm going to remember this
simplification right the common coin i
called it before magic con is now what
is a magic coin is a coin because two
labels two two phases zero or one
at each round the magic coin is spun
and a random beat golden br around r
appears to all players
ready go spin boom
in this case the coin end up zero and
all player good bad the cone is in the
sky think of it everybody can sin is
zero
okay it could have been one
so bit is a simplification
okay what ha what is the round r of the
magic coin pork what should play i do
now
every
[Music]
every theory talks should have that is
the beautiful things immoral then you
want to confuse people because you make
sure that there is theoretical death
whatever you're doing otherwise you
don't have a job okay i'm not good with
anything else deaths but still at this
time of the day is a little bit of
thinking sorry for straining you know
about two three neurons that i'm
available and at this time you know i'll
be straight so be patient with me if
you're straight that's the only reason
okay then you can go back to sleep
so at the beginning of the r i have a
coin that i've inherited from the
previous round i call it bi and play i r
minus 1.
now my question is
i see this coin local in my computer
is this the same bit that everybody else
does
i do not know
therefore
i'm going to
to say what does it mean to be the same
beat but b i bus one is equal b k r
minus 1 for all k
so that's what i want to do i'm going to
send my latest thought water by bit
candidate for a bit to everybody
everybody does the same so i immediately
at the next clock tick what happens i
receive
what people
tell me was their
latest
candidate beat
allegedly why because people can lie
people cannot send anything at all and i
have an empty message and so on so forth
and now i also receive i look up in the
sky and i look
at the magic coin br
and now i do
decide on a
round r coin as follows
if i receive a bit b from at least two
thirds of the people
i decide i i set b i plus one to bed b
else
i choose the coin in the sky
okay send receive whoever a candidate of
two thirds the majority that is my
decision i don't have 300 versions i do
it in the sky
you may have a different samples that's
okay but that's what i do very simple
what's the meaning of all this
here is the meaning let's assume that
around minus one we are in agreement
everybody has the same bit
then what happens all good people start
with the same bit
the number of good people by definition
is greater than two-thirds
all the good people sent two thirds
therefore all the good people received
the same beat b from two-thirds and
therefore all good people decide on b
independent on what the coin of the sky
is zero one doesn't matter
in other words if we are already in
agreement then we stay in agreement
i said this is good
well
if we are not in agreement then what
happens
case one
no good player k receives a bit b with
two thirds majority okay let's see that
no good player i'm good i don't have a
two for the majority you're good also
you don't have very majority what do we
do
then all the good players end up with a
bit in the sky
which by definition is the same overall
because that's the magic of it
then we agree immediately probability
one that's case one
what is case two well what is the
opposite of
no good player
some good player
k
receives a bit b with two thirds
majority some other player may also may
not who knows
but then that player
right ends up with a bit b if somebody
has received
a two-thirds majority
but then i claim that no other good
player k prime receives the opposite bit
with two thirds majority why because
if i receive a bit b for more than two
thirds
remember
more than one third are honest people so
that people
they say that big b anybody else has two
thirds minus one for the opposite you
cannot have two thirds
and therefore
if
the beat in the sky ends up being equal
to this bit b which has probability a
half
we are in agreement so in other words if
we are not in agreement
either in case one we again probability
one or in case two we'll give our
billionaire half
the end isn't that simple very simple
because there's magic on in the sky but
that was all right
okay
so
well if you
have paid attention is to say
if we are in agreement we stay in
agreement if we are not in agreement we
will get in the agreement but how do i
know
when we are in agreement i don't
that's a problem i agree
we have to do better than that and
second of all
magic coins
where
it's a very big help
okay
so let me tell you that we could do less
magic coins
is a coin that is spawned at every round
the probability two thirds the same
random beat is received by all
and here is a good magic case
everybody gets that's a bit zero because
the coin is zero and it is semi-good
right
and then we probably referred no coin or
no coin appears in the sky or the coin
is not random or not is not received by
all or a different people receive about
people the hell can go loose so with
two-thirds there is a good coin and
everybody receives and it is round and
one-third anything you want
so here is a for instance a bad magic
case people get the random stuff
somebody gets nothing somebody gets zero
somebody gets one
now what is the claim
the claim is with less magic coin we can
still get an agreement
but not to the probability half but the
probability of third
good enough
and the second claim is that the less
magic coins
are actually cryptographically
implementable and implementable fast
okay
is amazing right so
you go from something which is very
simple you can possibly get it so
something which is almost as magic best
you can get and you can get it quickly
okay
i'm going to show whatever happens this
but remember
that is synchronous
complete network
so the algorithm agreement
that is the gymnically agreement with
jing
jing is the chief scientist at algorand
hi jing
so and what do we do
we have to overcome a few things first
of all we must go from byzantine
agreement five minutes half a time
you know in my old age
i arrive early
and i finish on time i know i'm
surprised shopping
maybe i should make six minutes to be
according to tradition
okay
then
the communication model is really
adversarial
then
the bad guys
the player set is not fixed but changes
over time the adversary is dynamic
they we can detect determination and so
but most of all we have this beautiful
player representability policy that
nobody realizes what is needed but is
really the crack of the argument
and is actually faster so we're going to
do in three rounds rather than six
and a bunch of other things good so let
me jump to conclusions
because i want to prove that i can
finish in five minutes
you know what
that means that practice
needs a theory
and vice versa
you didn't get the joke but and vice
versa
because the practice in the series is
guaranteed
we have a few in its practice with uh we
don't know but we'll make it true
because if you notice that you know how
did we go about the stuff to solve a
really
important problem like
creating common knowledge with humanity
that's what the blockchain is
we went from this
35 years ago algorithm dream not to a
bunch of your edition with the gut
feeling that that was an important
problem and an entire community of
students colleagues and everybody else
felt they were going nobody had an idea
what the application was but it was in
my guts
but that was a good problem
and how do they go about they chose a
model which was
captured the essential parts and you can
reason about it and then you can enlarge
it and this ladies and gentlemen is
really the gift of theory and in
particular this is the gift of
theoretical fear
a computer scientist
so
i'd like to honor jim
and uh and dick and shafi for visual
with a wonderful 10 years out of a
simon's institute for theoretical
computer science thank you jim thank you
dick thank you shafi for taking us good
job
for 10 minutes
so but this let's remember we are
celebrating this 10 years because this
is the beginning of a long series so i'd
like to go forward onward
may this institute be honored so long as
making signs and lovingly handed down to
future generations remain honored valued
and all this
we can actually agree
thank you very much
okay
thanks sylvia for a beautiful talk uh
it's actually very striking to me
because you know i was never convinced
in the long ago as you said uh you know
it seemed to me byzantine agreement was
theoretically very interesting but the
motivation always seemed a little bit uh
lacking to me so this is this is
fantastic what what you've done
so the the question i have is this you
know it's clear that
you know what what you've done is you've
you've met a real need here in the sense
that so in the mask is interfering oh
sorry
what's clear is you've met a real need
here in the sense that you know what
what bitcoin does with proof of work is
just
i mean it's just crazy in in some sense
and
here you have an algorithm that's
practical that's uh theoretically
guaranteed
and obviously it's successful in the
sense that you're a company which is
successful but
what keeps it from
just being you know as a theoretician i
would say look you've solved the problem
shouldn't it just sweep away all the all
the competitors what's going on
well i'll tell you reminds me that the
winner shafi and i were gadget students
here right now and uh and uh public key
cryptography was uh coming up we felt
you know gee this is going to
conquer the world right we are going to
have everybody public key digital
signatures like your protocols
zero knowledge proof blah blah blah blah
we are going to
you know year one nothing year two
nothing you're free nothing our students
well they found that job maybe in
industry by hooking wires for security
and not proving anything anymore so year
10 year 20.
he had 25
something starts happening okay and then
by now but you know what i really made
the stuff worth here we were blockchain
because all of a sudden they really
needed to have public key
not click but didn't want to be
certified by anybody actually you want
to be a pseudonymity
so
it was a very
important lecture for me a lesson for me
in life so when i saw bitcoin and i
agree with you that it's a beautiful
idea and a beautiful philosophy behind
it but you know inelegant solution to
say there is i say you know what
let me did it so i did whatever
affirmation does i close myself in a
room for a month just ask my wife no
time for dinner time for that solution
okay so then
what
i decided do i want another 25 years you
know i may not have another 25 years so
all of a sudden i decide you know i'm
going to all my myself and i and and i
do it
because it is incredible good ideas
latch on eventually but we have no
control keynes used to say that the
market can remain irrational
much you know later when you remain
solvent so very often so sometimes you
know the same thing happens here the
ultimately good ideas latch on but we
don't know when and so sometime you know
when you think of it is really important
just to do it yourself at least you know
that's what i decided to do
[Applause]
okay